gérard a pris une résolution ils
s'abonnent au jimmy pour être certain de
tenir sa promesse
il paie six mois mais au bout d'un mois
le centre d'entraînement déclare
faillite ni gérard petit les me
rembourser pour les cinq mois qu'il n'a
pas utilisé
oui la loi a prévu des protections
spéciales visant les centres
d'entraînement pour obtenir leur permis
aux exploitants
ils doivent verser un cautionnement en
cas de faillite et le cautionnement
servira à indemniser les clients lésés
si évidemment le centre avait son permis
comme l'exigé la loi
heureusement pour gérard son centre un
permis il peut demander à l'office de la
protection du consommateur de
l'indemniser selon le nombre de clients
qui se partageront le cautionnement
gérard sera remboursé en tout ou en
partie
précision la loi n'offre pas cette
protection étudiants des centres de yoga
des écoles d'arts martiaux et les
studios de danse le fin mot de
l'histoire
avant de commencer vos redressement
ainsi vérifier donc si le gym a son
permis ou